vor vier Jahren verließ Massi ca Marie
ihre Heimat Iran und lebt seitdem als
politischer Flüchtling in Paris seit
langem ist sie politisch aktiv erst in
Iran heute in Frankreich sie engagiert
sich in einer iranischen Demokratie
Bewegung und unterstützt von hier aus
die Proteste gegen Kopftuchzwang und die
Herrschaft der Mullahs in Iran
ich habe viele Informationen über das
brutale Vorgehen der Sicherheitskräfte
im Internet geteilt dass sie die
Menschen in Iran töten ich kann
gegenüber den Ereignissen nicht
indifferent bleiben und ich hoffe dass
mein Volk in Iran diese Regierung
loswerden kann
sie war auch bei Demonstrationen vor der
iranischen Botschaft in Paris dabei
schrie ihre Wut gegen das regimeteran
heraus diese Regierung versucht nun sie
zum Schweigen zu bringen und benutzt
dafür ihre in Iran lebenden Eltern als
Druckmittel Ende Dezember klingelte bei
denen das Telefon
[Musik]
nicht vorbeikommt werden wir euch
festnehmen meine Eltern hatten keine
Wahl sie sind also dort hingegangen
jeder kennt die Adresse des Geheimdienst
Hauptquartiers in Teheran ein
berüchtigter Ort dort haben Sie das
Mobiltelefon meiner Mutter konfisziert
sie zeigten ihnen Fotos von mir in Paris
sie spielten ihn Mitschnitte von
Telefonaten vor die ich mit meinem Vater
geführt hatte sie haben meine Eltern
damit terrorisiert und in Angst
versetztung ich müsse mich an dem Tag
zwischen 19 und 22 Uhr bei Ihnen melden
weil der Druck auf meine Eltern so groß
geworden war habe ich an dem Abend
schließlich die Nummer meiner Mutter
angerufen
dieses Gespräch hat sie aufgezeichnet
und sie entschied sich damit an die
Öffentlichkeit zu gehen wenn wir uns
einschüchtern lassen und Schweigen wird
sich nie etwas ändern sagt sie hier ein
kurzer Auszug aus dem Gespräch
hören sie junge Frau was sie da machen
verstößt gegen die Gesetze der
islamischen repub
lik Augens gegen die islamische Republik
zu rufen oder an Demonstrationen
teilzunehmen
ich kann mit meiner Familie private
Gespräche führen wie ich will das ist
kein Verbrechen was meine Familie tut
entscheidet sie selbst nein das ist nach
unserer Meinung ein Verbrechen jede ihre
Handlungen in Frankreich gegen die
islamische Republik sind ein Verbrechen
wir werden Ihre Familie in Iran dafür
zur Verantwortung ziehen
nach irgendwo auf der Welt werden
Familien für ein Verbrechen in
Sippenhaft genommen
hier machen wir das so wenn Sie glauben
ich hätte ein Verbrechen begangen bitten
Sie doch Interpol mich festzunehmen
nun wenn sie so weitermachen wie bisher
werden wir hier sehen wir am Ende dafür
bezahlt Ende dieser Woche wird ihre
Familie ins Gefängnis wandern sie wollen
meine Familie sie bedrohen mich schon
wieder ja genau
he ihn okay wenn ihr glaubt dass ihr
Dokumente gegen mich in der Hand habt
und deswegen meine Eltern mitnehmen
wollt dann mach das ich werde nicht
aufhören es gibt nirgendwo auf der Welt
eingesetzt dass wenn sich jemand
strafbar macht jemand anderes dafür zu
Verantwortung gezogen wird dann habe ich
das Telefonat beendet und auch den
Kontakt zu meiner Familie abgebrochen
ein Regime bedroht seine Bürger nimmt
sie fest foltert tötet sie rund 19.000
Festnahmen gab es im Zusammenhang mit
den Protesten bisher vier Todesurteile
wurden vollstreckt sich gegen dieses
Regime aufzulehnen dazu gehört Mut
was auch immer sie meinen Eltern antun
dafür trägt die Islamische Republik die
alleinige Verantwortung das ist nicht
mein Fehler oder irgendjemanden sie sind
verantwortlich
ja das ist alles sehr beängstigend aber
ich sage mir ich habe 38 Jahre in Iran
gelebt jeden Tag hatte ich damals Angst
schlimmer kann es nicht werden doch ich
hoffe dass dieser Angst eines Tages
endet
noch aber verfolgt das Regime seine
Gegner auch im Ausland vorgestern erst
demonstrierten über 10.000 Menschen vor
dem Europaparlament in Straßburg ihre
Forderung die iranischen
revolutionsgarten auf die internationale
Terrorliste zu setzen und weitere
Sanktionen gegen die Führung der
Islamischen Republik zu verhängen die
aber hat tausende Spitzel die Gegner im
Ausland ausspionieren und die Familien
in Iran massiv Bedrohung der Information
dass sie so viele Informationen über
mich gesammelt haben das ist schon
seltsam
ich muss sagen ich habe schon ein
bisschen Angst
ich weiß nicht was sie tun werden
aber sie haben meine Eltern bespitzelt
und unsere Gespräche aufgezeichnet
offenbar hatten sie Zugang zu
Informationen
vielleicht hören sie mich ab oder
beschatten mich ich habe keine Ahnung
[Musik]
viele beugen sich diesem Druck
massi-ka-marie aber will das nicht tun
ich habe versucht stark zu sein am Ende
habe ich gesagt ich werde nicht tun was
ihr von mir verlangt ich werde euch
nicht mehr zuhören
ich werde mich euren Drohungen nicht
beugen aber es war sehr sehr hart
das ist nun zwei Wochen her noch hat
sich der Geheimdienst Mann nicht mehr
gemeldet doch jede Minute kann das
Telefon klingeln fürchtet Maxi ca Marie
die Nachricht dass ihre Eltern für den
Protest der Tochter büßen müssen
trotzdem ich habe keine Wahl sagt sie
ich muss reden ich muss mich wehren auch
wenn es mir das Herz bricht
[Musik]